grade your performance this year I'm
probably one of my biggest critics and
part of myself is there anyone just
kawaii weakness you can chip out a
little bit so everybody stand agree
Los Angeles Laker proud tongue roll
along and I'm going to take it there at
tail ropes bring her to the animal
kingdom to check out some snakes
tarantulas scorpions crocodiles you name
it it's an experience of a lifetime
we're gonna take it there tell Danny
he's got a spinning your off day at the
reptile zoo surrounded by all of these
snakes and reptiles and everything so my
question is why snakes oh not just
Nick's but all animals reptiles I think
is very unique took interest in how they
eat how they operate so appreciate the
opportunity to do this and show you
around a little bit and she shoots
through the reptile world yes as we are
there's a lot of reptiles reptile
questions for the reptile guy I'm gonna
say some NBA players you tell me what
reptile they are what fits them okay
LeBron James you know that low I don't
know I don't know what Connie iguanas
that runs on water okay
he is a fast guy or more so of how he
act let accusin explicity is reflexes
and also to be aware of his surroundings
Davis Oh miss so many reptiles to
describe him yeah you can go with like a
komodo dragon or a big lizard it's hard
to describe him because of how long an
active he is and said his reflexes are
his size Yanis Yanis uh I would say like
a squid octopus like that they can be
very big with the explosive they can
shoot very fast and travel fast in water
Kyrie Irving Kyrie I was positive
community you can adapt them adjust to
many different plans means aren't big
they're able to blend in they hi they're
also able to surprise you
so I was reading a lot about snakes with
why I came here yeah you learned some
snakes are cold-blooded of course
are you cold blooded on a court I try to
be most of it is mental you're going
with that cold-blooded mentality
Muhammad mentality it allows you to be
more focused locked in and less fear of
making mistakes and just playing and
having fun grade your performance this
year I'm probably one of my biggest
critics are myself I'll give myself
probably b-minus c-plus I'm used to
garden the more guy and now Avery's got
that and offensively I'm used to doing
this doing that now just stay in the
corner make sure I space or set screens
so figure that out but um I'm figuring
out I'm getting better at its perks here
and there but probably C + B - are you
the best role player in the NBA I
wouldn't say that I try to be the best
role player from my team my job
is the play defense most of time and
knock down shots in space before and
make it easier for us our stars to
operate on LeBron ad you know we have
Dwight Howard was was a great role block
of shots the bell bleep kitchen lobs so
I just folks I'm trying to be the best I
can be for our team yes but obviously
that's a goal to have and they don't
give a word for that but you know I take
pride in it when you talk about being a
player talk about playing any sport you
think success comes with being the
greatest but really a success comes with
being the greatest at whatever exactly
um I always like you know coach Phil
handy he's one of our assistant coaches
you know be your own goal so if you must
be in the greatest good being your
greatest facing you guys have what you
do or being the best you and I know what
I'm capable of doing whatever they need
to do you get your best self on and off
the floor
let's talk free agency for a little bit
before obviously deciding to be a Laker
I heard you were potentially gonna be a
maverick or you thought about it there
were some rumors yes walk me through the
free agency process Dallas is very into
labor versus Lakers to me what
frontrunner because of the pieces they
had
now Dallas had some really good pieces
of I think would take a year to spend to
be in that conversation but yes those
are the two frontrunners you know
outside of Toronto and with Toronto were
able to offer or not offer it was then
you know Lakers in Dallas yeah you
shuffled you know around different teams
allows you've had different coaches
different players how do you start to
feel like home do teams start to feel
like home for you yeah I think it's a
lot more a lot of us here felt at home
sooner than we expected to because of
how fast we gels as a group learning
each other on and off the floor and then
winning and also said having a culture
building a culture off the court I think
it makes you okay to help us out and
help you come to keep you calm I am want
to help you guys today yes ever since I
was a kid I always wanted some snakes
and stuff like that and my mom said I
couldn't have him in her house so once I
got out of her house I was like I gotta
get me some snakes more so I have a big
collection of snakes a wide variety oh
my god it's not many snake people in the
league yeah so when we find out about
each other we have like this weird
random bond who else is there so we
don't know that Oh Robert
okay and now
since that later he's the man right in
you just touch it yeah there you go
you already raised very pretty right you
never really want to go and grab where
the head is at first because to them
it's like seeing a big bird or creature
trying to grab them so they might get a
little nervous so you always sought I
always try to grab them in their
midsection or whatever okay then I'll
just left in you know do what they do
okay okay I'm great so now when you see
a wraparound like that he's just yeah oh
you probably like my hair
you have played for three very good
coaches but for many good coaches but
obviously vogel nurse Popovich compare
and contrast their coaching styles
because I'm sure they're vastly
different for sure I think those ball
going pop are very similar the fact that
they're more defensive coaches pop if
you don't play defense you're not
playing offense so you're not playing at
all basically here so Frank is kind of
the same that sense but not as as a
stickler as pop was Nick obviously he
emphasized offense but he's more of an
offensive coach he likes to push the
pace get them down good shots so I had a
lot of fun you had more freedom a lot of
freedom the offense we push the pace one
cool thing though and you've been on so
many teams some great players you know
the ins and outs you figure out those
players weaknesses maybe how to stop
them a little bit how do you stop Kawhi
well that's what all great players there
is no real stopping them it's trying to
contain it give me the playbook we're
trying to contain Kawhi I think the best
thing from just with any superstars try
to limit his touches and try not let him
catch the ball where he wants to try to
deny him some double-team so throw
different looks out I don't he's a tough
player and you know I said I know what
he's gonna do and I still can't stop
yeah that's what makes him great is
there any like just Kauai weakness you
can chip out a little bit in his game no
not really an in fact if I did I
wouldn't I wouldn't so how would you
describe Kauai because they feel like a
lot of people probably don't get it
he's a normal person which is very
simple and likes things the way he likes
things he's the type of guy I just you
know wants to be in the shadows but also
be great at what he does while I have
two Lakers here I have a question for
you guys cuz I have been wondering this
take me into this like Caruso craze
everyone loves gurus ago I guess and the
league is not a lot of white guys
yeah he's one of very few that's very
athletic yeah a little flavor and oh
yeah it's all dirty work and people
loved it oh I would say he would be
albino Wow are those big dragons like
fight hard this could be AC right this
is probably better to pet an oddest race
there you go give him good support
[Music]
unlike a snake he doesn't want to treat
what he wants to feel like he's on the
ground so lots of belly support and he
should settle funny little thing but did
you really get drug tested after that
Dutch against the Hawks I really I did
the next day yeah so it happened Mexican
thing was me I'll screw so he's enough
of that kind of gets tested here and
there it's hard to believe to him do
what he does I guess on the floor
athletically so they always testing a
lot of times with me I'm older and seem
to do that in a while
now obviously that was a good dunk that
you had you've got dunk time a couple
times here
Jason Tatum I think is the one that
sticks out to a lot of people yes I hate
to take him one man to beat
he's very athletic he's tall guard and
it happened so fast that's it when I
happened I try to like just cut him off
but it was just too late yeah okay
besides the obvious ones mm-hmm toughest
to defend I think the non-obvious guys
to defend it wasn't like the James
Harden the Kevin Durant's but the ones
that are not obviously the guys that run
around so much like the JJ redick's the
Kyle Korver's you chasing them off three
or four screens of seven footers centers
you know in DeAndre or Blake was setting
screen for JJ I'm using the Clippers so
I think those guys are the ones were
tougher to guard from me that were not
the obvious ones both have to give it to
me at all times point guard magic jumps
k2 guard breathe I gotta go abroad for
this
Ronit 30 ABF and so on a team with
LeBron James and Anthony Davis obviously
the Brian carries alive the low he's the
Brian James but Anthony Davis is also a
star in a great basketball player
what is that dynamic like being on a
team that has these two just all-around
studs I love it they embrace each other
there that's the firm hangout which I
didn't also embrace us
besides chemistry what is going to be
the thing that sex
the Lakers apart our leaders are two
stars also I think our depth that we
have so many guys that complain about
playing well that we don't have enough
minutes to play in the game it's not
about us it's about the team so we don't
really care about them as long as we're
winning and playing well you guys are
fine with it
Lakers good enough to win it all for
sure definitely we just have to have to
do it can't it's expected to happen yeah
I make it happen
laughs Tom combs being locked in doubt
into the matchups that we have who's the
stiffest competition for the Lakers so a
team I think there's more than more than
in the West I think there's a lot of
them in the east of course in the world
you're healthy Austin the very time you
seen it mentioned is very tough magic I
couldn't be a Finals
you never know preview you have three or
four teams in the West through four
teams knees that can come out each side
and then it makes it more exciting for
basketball fans to watch you mentioned
the Lakers Celtics game this year
great game what is that robbery like
does it feel different than others for
sure it's very new to me
yeah so I didn't know what to expect
each time we play the music very much
like a plan I rarely do you see a
rivalry between two teams from different
coasts in different conferences now you
said who knows
looking at the Laker Celtics game could
be Finals preview so in this
hypothetical row let's say you're
playing the Celtics in the finals let's
kind of run through that starting five
tell me what problems each of those
players gives the lake I'll just start
what Campbell were talking when I was in
the league very crafty and with that
system you're not able to double to them
he's a tough cover Jason Tatum young
rising all-star obviously it's all along
I've let it guard but it can handle it
like a point guard and it has you know
plethora of moves and can shoot jaylen
Brown very athletic big guard plays in
the post on slasher but said is it
shooter as well another tough cover for
in Hayward use an all-star go both ways
shoot it has a good amount of moves as
well and shoots it from perimeter Marcus
smart the guy with an edge scrappy
defensive player but also shoot a very
welcome perimeter they have so many
different guys that can do different
things it's a massive problem for any
team I have done so many new things I'll
join the reptile guy thank you so much
for having white for being a all right
Danny so I play this game every guest
pick one do not waiver and tell me why
okay true or false
and why score okay why no I think we
have a lot of great players come from
there pretty good all right but you have
to say out of the way
true or false and why Staples Center is
now the mecca back true over the garden
yes a Staples Center now has two very
great emerging team
and saying the mecca but it's becoming
this might have been my favorite episode
in terms of the things that we had to do
thank you so much for having me like
hang out all these reptiles and see
something you are clearly very
passionate about but thank you for the
opportunity thank you for bringing the
hero to me Jay and also experience this
there's a lot of fun there's definite
experience I'll never forget it
absolutely be a snake will keep the
Mamba mentality exactly absolutely
thanks Danny thank you
hey guys it's Taylor extinct you so much
for watching my show take it there but
now that means you have to subscribe to
the YouTube channel you don't want to
miss all the fun stuff or the next
interview so hit that subscribe button
thanks so much see you soon